we don't want to make anyone cry but our
sad days in the publishing world in
Australia I don't know if you're aware
of this but I'm afraid dolly magazine
has shut its doors dolly magazine is no
more dolly magazine was very important
to you when you were starting out wasn't
it yeah yeah I got on the cover of dolly
magazine there we go you are stunning
giant facetious no I dyed my hair red
not sounding like 14 but sure it wasn't
red like that everyone always thinks it
was that redness wasn't no they dyed it
red inside though some fabulous
high-fashion shots of you know of the
quality of fashion in dolly magazine
it's a lovely shiny jacket I think these
ropes Eames
I'm not sure they ever caught on the
rope see I've never seen it before but
more so I honestly wish my hair was like
that now and so it's because I have to
say anyone that has curly hair that's
young keep your curly hair don't
straighten it because after a while you
don't get your curls back no no they
just do they kind of become just frizz
mess
I mean that is frizz mess but I kind of
like yeah it's gone so I'm like an old
woman now where I say don't straight new
girls photographers in movies when
they're doing a shoot and there was a
cold look sexy or give me something give
me this or you know try this what had a
photographer said this picture are you
doing this to anybody
[Applause]
is this the sort of thing you roster
can I see your pump we'll take it away
we'll take it away there you go
dolly magazine r.i.p
[Music]
you